des cris qui retentissent au coeur des
décombres mais des cris de joie des
enfants palestiniens partagent un moment
de gaieté en compagnie de clowns et deux
doigts levés pour un appel à l'aide et à
la paix appel entendu du côté de doha le
qatar a annoncé mercredi une aide de 500
millions de dollars pour la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza une
journée marquée d'ailleurs par les
promesses du chef du bureau politique du
hamas
après onze jours de conflit en coûté la
vie à plus de 250 personnes
le mouvement islamiste a assuré qu'aucun
centime de l'aide internationale à la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza ne
seraient détournés promettant un
processus transparent et impartial à
yacine war constructif mais aussi
vindicatif se mue en plus que jamais en
chef de la résistance palestinienne
vous savez et le monde entier sait
quelles sont les véritables raisons qui
ont conduit à la récente escalade des
violences liées aux pratiques de
l'occupation à jérusalem à la mosquée al
qassas à cheikh jarrah et en général il
est impératif que notre peuple et notre
résistance est leur mot à dire et met en
oeuvre les avertissements des
dirigeantes de notre peuple contre cette
occupation des promesses scrutées alors
que l'occident se tourner vers le proche
orient
ces dernières heures les rencontres
diplomatiques se multiplient
le ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères dominique rave et partir à la
rencontre des deux camps
objectif consolider le cessez le feu
entré en vigueur le 21 mai bien sûr nous
voulons que le cessez-le-feu soit
respectée nous voulons soutenir israël
mais nous voulons aussi que les
palestiniens trouvent une voie vers une
paix durable
c'est peut-être difficile pour l'instant
mais nous devons continuer à essayer
nous fournissons une aide humanitaire et
de secours en cisjordanie à gaza
nous apportons notre soutien merci et
merci à vous et au premier ministre
boris johnson pour le soutien ferme et
inébranlable de notre droit à
l'autodéfense lors de la récente
opération ce fut très appréciée la
grande-bretagne pays alliés mais aussi
favorable à une solution à deux états
qui passe par une stabilité au sein de
la région tout comme les états unis
anthony blinken bras droit du président
américain n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de
se rendre en egypte puis en jordanie
deux nations ayant signé un traité de
paix avec israël
la france s'est par ailleurs inquiétée
par la voix de son chef de la diplomatie
jean yves le drian d'un risque
d'apartheid
après les violences observées entre
communautés juifs et arabes
une analyse qualifié de leçon de morale
hypocrite et mensongères par benyamin
nétanyahou